The Times ran a piece today called
abolish billionaires because not enough
of them pledged to give away most of
their wealth to charity
now they don't say how much the rich
actually give away or all the people
they've hired the benefits they offer
the taxes they pay they also don't
mention that at times principal
stockholder is worth 60 billion but
who's counting right there are only
2,000 billionaires worldwide so you know
it's not really about them it's about as
always the the evil system this ban is
about the power to say who gets
abolished and who's invited to the
abolition party it's driven by man's
worst flaw envy
fact is our system rules as capitalism
spreads worldwide poverty declines
disease drops and Seth Meyers stays
employed no more smallpox no more
starvation if this continues the rich
will only have other rich people to give
money to and it's not inequality that
defines the system it's mobility the
same person and the top 10% wasn't there
ten years ago it may not be there in ten
years opportunity is defined not by
inequality between me and you but
between you now and you later
what exception the souls burgers the
times owners they're super rich decades
ago and they'll stay that way decades
from now tricking readers into thinking
they care about the poor finally the
author whines about hack technology
creates immense wealth for its inventors
and that's bad yet the average 20 year
old has more power in a smartphone than
Howard Hughes had at the height of his
empire we work less because technology
works more for that you can thank the
rich before you hang them in the town
square
Jesse interesting fact from Mark J Perry
who is really good at this stuff 73% of
Americans we're in the top 20% for at
least a year
so that means they're moving in they're
moving out that's a fact that slips by
all the shallow declarations of
inequality let's cut to the chase Greg
yes countries full of idiots idiots are
harmless when they stick by themselves
you know they run out of gas in the
highway they vote for Gary Johnson
that's fine is what idiots join forces
and this is what happened in this op-ed
the guy that writes this op-ed is an
idiot
his last column was titled there's
nothing wrong with open borders okay so
this genius gives a platform to this
Marxist the rights for Gawker the guys
other column he writes is from mmm daily
that's the name of his blog let's
abolish the free market system with wage
controls in and cease wealth okay
obviously it's illegal it's
unconstitutional it's on American and
it's immoral
so other idiots read the times and they
think wow abolished billionaires that
sounds fair and they start scratching
their heads this is the paper record
this is what I call an idiot brush fire
everybody starts talking about
abolishing billionaires and it spreads
and then we have to come in and put out
the yes we get burned putting out the
fire because you want to know why we're
sitting around defending billionaire
that's the point no we look like idiots
Dagan because we're defending the
greatest economic system known to man
there's been an 80% reduction in
worldwide poverty in 36 years and it
ain't due to socialism it's due to
capitalism and I just want to point out
the great liberal lie is that the rich
are somehow the billionaires are gonna
pay for all these delicious programs
that they're rolling out today it's the
green New Deal here's a little fact if
you confiscate it every dollar of the
adjusted gross income reported by the
top 1% in this country every year you're
still gonna be more than a trillion
dollars short paying for your
medicare-for-all plan which by the way
abolish is private insurance code jumps
150 million people off of the insurance
they get from their employers that's the
idiocy but you can't pay for it all you
new pays for it the middle class and
people who are in lower income why
Europe let me you run out of the rich
let me just say that you know what
there's something called income
inequality in America that's growing and
it's a huge political issue
destroy that hour so you go about this
and by the way Greg you're so sensitive
on artificial intelligence and growing
part of the argument is fewer people are
required to do very simple work and
maybe even truck driving yes actually
driving we've talked about I agree and
so those people don't have jobs and then
guess what the people who are in
high-tech they're becoming billionaires
at a rapid rate so you have more people
who control not only financial power but
political power they get to tell us how
to live what to do and guess what most
Americans say we don't like it we want
to have a voice in our political
structure and we should not all be
living as serfs on the masters Kingdom
that's ridiculous Dana okay so I have
something and that I'm gonna call I
don't have it there is a thing okay as
Bo okay
selective billionaire outraged yeah so
there are certain billionaires that they
hate more than others right okay so like
Bill Gates he's basically helped solve a
lot of the world's health problem right
right right and with his money and his
efforts and like it tireless efforts
good billionaire mmm-hmm okay Tom Styer
mmm-hmm funds all their political
campaigns as long as you're for me he's
a better billionaire he's a good know
he's better than gates because he's
politically correct
no bad billionaire doesn't matter that
you have the you know yeah all the stuff
that they hospitals in the hospital I
think I'm pointing up there that's where
the hospital is and then the ultimate
billionaire the hate is strong yeah for
every reason Under the Sun yeah it's a
good points Bo SBO
it sounds like something more disgusting
I have s Bo but frankly there's a drug
for it